el festival internacional de cine de
venecia se concluyó este sábado
entregando el león de oro a la película
no más grande la directora
estadounidense de origen chino yao es la
primera mujer en los últimos diez años
que recibe este prestigioso galardón con
esta película que narra de los
trabajadores nómadas de los eeuu por
otro lado la película nuevo orden del
mexicano michel franco único
largometraje latinoamericano en la
selección oficial ganó el león de plata
y también el león sino de orona es un
premio otorgado por un jurado de jóvenes
esta película hace un retrato despiadado
de la sociedad mexicana azotada por las
diferencias sociales en el palmarés se
destacan también el león de plata al
mejor director aquí yo sí kurosawa por
la mujer del espía el premio al mejor
guión a chaitanya tamane por el
discípulo y en la selección paralela la
sección 'horizontes el premio al mejor
cortometraje a la colombiana mariana
sazón por su corto bautizado entre tú y
milagros más allá de los galardones
cinematográficos esta mostra
logró una proeza sanitaria es el primer
festival de cine internacional que se
llevó a cabo en medio de la pandemia y
gracias a un estricto protocolo
sanitario este festival logró hacer
renacer el séptimo arte sin crear focos
infecciosos de coronavirus